cat fetches it's your boy psychobabble
or [ __ ] back and we're about to do
some traps outside okay - okay ladies
okay
what does um yes cool
oh [ __ ] that guy's so ugly a lot -
forgot Jeff okay
oh god my legs I can't feel them - wait
for me which why pizza I can't say ah
nice house rich okay I need to check my
Twitter feed okay if you guys can hurry
up I just signed up time for work
opposite color just trying to help the
right yeah yeah get out of there maybe I
can I take their bed a lot better what
happened our joking [ __ ] I go uh kind of
shitty bill all right yeah strange
sensation trapped in my body not
blackout
in time sometimes a seasons change the
blink of an eye I'm having trouble with
my plans right we dissipate like a
sentinel in a counteroffer well I got
the wall to get to talk about I'm like
Poland hospital oh that's an asylum
she's head nurse that's our product
Shrek
never made some of that performances I
run the place I reckon that's Christmas
sometimes birthdays sometimes Nazis car
they leave rotations and shackles that
death personal candy store the shrink
raises Helen all but in the end he sighs
no choice huh suppose no see how the
size that booth folks made powerless
Ally because in these people I'm getting
better because of her
her name is Anya Anya he takes good care
of me she takes care of every honey I
would ply your brain around this place
together supposed to be married by now
but hasn't happened this guy with tongue
her ass all cozy she look Spanish okay
my legs will be attribution I gotta go
Sam
you know things didn't sting up annuity
[Music]
you have to scream stay in the avec you
life and that late today in Russia not
Imam the Chuckle air oh it's Kevin [ __ ]
and ya know a chef like if one comin out
of your ears I was in Ecbatana to be
hanging on over Vince - Keller
my Anya what have I done
Thank You charlie yeah if I attributed
spot
all right I'm gonna flood some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] up
hello Sarge should be made to Darla well
the cat that was there there's a cat
rolling there say yeah okay
collectibles no I think it's [ __ ]
hi Dania that part of the South they
took I didn't get finer get our away
from this box one okay okay all right
let's do this
oh it's a Glock ilayk [ __ ] [ __ ] shits
get little crazy
but the Fox in yours you suck a dick all
right oh now please as that I'll paste
at that rocky papasano Lisa I'm in the
wrong place at the wrong time
enjoy oh yeah you like that
second deck for prayerfully Maude oh
yeah baby oh yeah you like it
how sweet business of yours oh shoot
folks can't decide themselves
I forgot how I write they just check the
tape is any [ __ ] what's going on here
Omega intesity
hello that's a [ __ ] maid
I don't know where the [ __ ] I'm gone
[Applause]
how pays em [ __ ]
I need that help I just saw [ __ ] out
somewhere yeah level [ __ ] I need to take
a long time oh okay I don't know where
the [ __ ] I should be going
and I got a lower aim if I just use
[ __ ] one and I can actually aim now to
close over here they exit the top spot
where is it open that's where I got to
go you like that [ __ ] now what's up
[ __ ]
Chasez yeah I look at my pain right now
I should comes open that but there's
something I should do you [ __ ] nut
okay let's shake anything nowadays
around nowadays and God open elsewhere
it's a [ __ ]
Oh like I said it first of all oh yeah
yeah yeah
a health upgrade [ __ ] it I finally there
we go holy [ __ ] they're all like right
here oh good I'll speed this up
oh Allah do sitting on it
you get double ammo I love you like that
[ __ ] anyone else when I [ __ ] with the
rest and I like the rest okay let me get
the [ __ ] outta here
ah if you're grinning at me but I'm not
running because I'm at a little [ __ ]
out okay guys in here let's [ __ ] the Taz
look
so [ __ ] is that
is that right
where is that
okay [ __ ] how Fania Anya okay baby
okay oh yeah
I'll get you out of here that a tear
[Music]
okay I'll be pizza oh yeah good I'll be
this much good
oh yeah sit here tonight thank you for
riding with that blast oh it's
enterprise infinite respect genius
mr. William James black emission raise
your size USA USA I'm sorry I pause it
very good are you fit to drive
we're - we're Americans
oh shut the [ __ ] up do the back [ __ ] him
up and agree from there dead
Soros can't partake with flood oceans
with drown I have very sad
[Music]
it's 1960 1960 yeah [ __ ] it's been like
20 years with us for 14 years
it's 1960
I have to find a way to contact the US
military I gotta find my unit let the
normalize but really there's no more war
it's over no for really no the war I
know we're look at all these Nazis
walking around day one it's over denied
she screwed the words now they're
everywhere everywhere what about the US
USA with the word hope that you holy
[ __ ] I serious surrendered because of
who I some gone they surrendered 12
years ago when Nazi atompub their
country yes well then I'll find the
resistance I'll find them and I'll help
them fight more resistance
everyone is captured if they leave did
not you have them and who can say well
they came them
[Music]
okay that was chapter two that gal for
watching I help yell on God thank ya